yo I'm Ryan Wright today I'm gonna be
checking out the trailer for creep the
boo boo boo boo who did anyway I'm a
janitor for Cree today I'm actually
interested in seeing this film if you
guys have seen the Rocky movies Apollo
Creed was a major supporting character
now it's about Apollo Creed's son who is
being trained my none other than rocky
balboa being played again by sylvester
the stallone i know a lot of people are
already upset at this idea like you've
already mad about it but if you guys
remember when rocky balboa was released
the six rocky everyone was like against
it everyone was like this is stupid
Stallone's in his sixties like how the
hell could they pull this off this is
dumb and then the movie came out or most
people especially Rocky fans really
liked the film so I think this could be
a nice surprise it could be an
interesting turn who knows the trailer
will say more than what my anticipation
thoughts are of the trailer
[Music]
Wow Human Torch himself
you
[Music]
not built for this these boys come in
here they gotta fight for life people
die in the ring your daddy died in the
ring all know how it spoiler I'm doing
me
[Music]
let me fight in my whole life it's not a
choice for me every punch everyone's
been I'm off my shoulders right swipes
in the Friday football weather better
better caviar dirty needles
yeah man boxing pitches from the 10th
round in the first place
right I heard about a third fight
between Apollo
well closed doors that's rude how do you
know all this his son
every hybrid a great father once said it
ain't about how hard it
it's about how far you can keep moving
forward that's the one I just got here
that's the toughest opponent you're ever
going out to face I've any less true
Arun and I think that's true life there
show me something that you know what
first off I got that quote wrong but I
know it's from Rocky Balboa okay so I
know where the line originates from but
the movie like I'm a little bit
overwhelmed with like I find that kind
of cool it's a spinoff slash sequel and
it's right it's not Rocky story at all
but like having Rocky there as a
supporting player is a unique way to
take advantage of this world in this
character you know I'm glad that it
wasn't a movie where it's like this is
about Apollo Creed's son but we're gonna
ignore Rocky
they just haven't be a main supporting
character I think that's really neat to
do that like because we've seen Rocky as
the main character this is a totally
separate film that features rocky that's
awesome film kind of looks like
eight-mile but with boxing kind of like
the tone not necessarily a story but
Michael B Jordan and he looks like he
like he looks like a legit fighter in
this I don't know if he has experience
before doing boxing or martial arts but
he looks like a real [ __ ] boxer in
this movie as far as that trailer goes
this song that was going over it
beautiful that whole trailer just moved
me man it's interesting it kind of
reminds me of if you guys watch Kill
Bill uma Thurman gets a sword from a
character called hattori hanzo this
character was I think the actor's name
was Sonny Chiba I think I got that wrong
already but I think that's what it is he
did a character a Tori Hanzo in the
television show and then there was this
movie called Kill Bill and Tarantino
decided to cast Sonny Chiba in it with
him playing hattori hanzo so it's not a
toreano sequel it's not a Victorian
Hanzo film but it features him in a
continuation version that's what I like
about what they're doing this because I
can already tell this is gonna be the
biggest complaint like oh we got another
Rocky movie but I just don't feel that
way and I
love the dark imagery the dark tones to
it there's there's a grittier feel but
there's some obvious omage is too rocky
but it's actually has a rather like dark
layer to it it feels more gritty than
any of the Rocky movies ever were I mean
this is just a trailer don't want to get
my hopes up too high but it does look
[ __ ] sweet if you guys are new to the
channel you can subscribe to the Rio
rejects you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter and vine where if we
get enough followers we can get product
placement for things such as cats cats
are great um
Veronica and I just got these kittens
this one is too shy for a camera and
it's clawing its way into my back right
now yelling in his ear it's cuz I'm
talking to the audience
meet Darth Maul I'm joking yeah I don't
have a product placement sex joke I just
want her to show off my new cats we're
parents I know we have a real kid on the
way
cut the black